hey guys I think today I'll be making
this thing called Kohaku toh which is
the super cool-looking candy from Japan
what's really interesting about these
candies is that it actually ends up
looking almost like glass it takes on
this like translucent quality which I
thought was pretty awesome hopefully
they will look as pretty as I saw them
to be let's get going again
this recipe is fairly simple we only
really need three ingredients we need
some sort of liquid could use water if
you want I chose a passion fruit pear
juice I figured this would give it a
little bit more foodie flavor agar agar
which works kind of like gelatin but
it's made of completely different things
it also helps give whatever you're
making that jelly like quality we also
need as per usual a lot of sugar I
promise it will be really good and
really sweet like a very sweet we're
gonna turn this on and pour the juice in
first passionfruit smells so good now
we're gonna add the agar agar stir it
gently so then the agar doesn't stick to
the bottom you two five minutes I would
say while we're waiting for that I
wanted to show you guys a couple molds
that I bought these gem shaped molds if
we poured the candy mixture into here it
would pop out as gems I also have these
these are actual earring molds and these
are like necklace like amulet molds I
don't know if this is gonna work this is
just me trying to be creative angers
cross molds aside I also have just a
regular pan and I old a little bit so it
doesn't stick this should be there's
some steam coming out it's time for
sugar this is a lot of sugar it's like a
little mountain this is still on super
low heat slowly melt this down let the
sugar dissolve just gonna let it slowly
heat up
all righty it is now boiling it's
slightly thicker we're gonna have to run
this through a mesh strainer whoo-hoo oh
that's good that tastes like
passionfruit candy it's so good okay so
this is the part where we have to work
kind of fast I am actually going to try
to fill these up first here goes nothing
I don't want to accidentally spill it as
I say that I spilled it I'm using this
dropper we're gonna go in with this
whoo-hoo I'm like super slow right now
better safe than sorry
better slow than sorry great sound just
gonna fill up a little bit of these and
then the rest I'm just gonna pour it in
here now we've poured all the candy out
we're gonna go in with some food
coloring to make it look pretty where's
my food coloring oh it's right here it
would actually be such a cool idea to
try and make Infinity stones like in
Avengers let's do this it's gonna start
off with red let's see if this works
oh it's so pretty orange yellow green
blue then purple OH
there we have the Infinity stones coat
and coat and we can make a rainbow in
this one so I'm just gonna splash these
on let's try to blend these together
this is looking super nice guys
it's like tie-dye but like with candy
same thing with these ones oh no it's
already solidifying I'm just not gonna
mess with these because I think I waited
too long we're just gonna focus on the
necklaces just going to add a bit of
color and swirl it a little bit make
them look pretty I don't know if I'm
really being successful with that right
now kind of just winging this you have
to work really fast with these you just
pour it out in a pan that's probably the
easiest thing to do so what I'm gonna do
now is actually put it in the fridge let
it chill for two hours hopefully it sets
after it sets we'll try to pop them out
if they're intact then we can go from
there
off to the fridge you go time to chill
okay so it's been two hours I just
pulled these from the fridge they have
now completely solidified
it looks pretty good it actually looks
the exact same as it did two hours ago
only difference is that it's not falling
out really the I feel that actually
didn't fall out these are also now in
solid form there's a nice shine to it
it's a bit floppy the trick here now is
to take it out carefully and hope that
it stays intact knowing me
there is a huge chance that we might
actually break these here goes nothing
let's try to pop these out no this is so
slowly but surely oh my god oh my god
whoo there we go
you see that right now it doesn't really
look gem like it just looks like jello
shaped in a gem form it will get there
but for right now I'm just happy that it
came out in one piece so we're gonna set
this down here tada
here's our green one basically that's it
we're just gonna slowly take all of
these out I love this side it looks so
pretty purple really just looks black
infinity stones this is my geek moment
okay and I want to put this down before
I drop it oh that is pretty cool you can
see the hole in the middle we can easily
make this into a necklace the color came
out so cool dough turned out pretty cool
I'm feeling good about this
hope the streak continues our rainbow
one it looks so cool I'm gonna pop these
earring ones out whoa two little
teardrops hopefully we can actually make
these into earrings so I'm gonna set
these here now for this one we just need
to carefully try to take it out and I
can cut it into strips how do you take
this out it's tearing apart no no no no
no no whoo I tore it this is what it
looks like this is what my hand looks
like that's okay
like so could just tear this just to get
that like jagged glass effects so these
are our little broken shards cut these
in two square shapes and that is a
perfect square shape
I have a small strip left I have these
little flower cutouts that I'm gonna use
like this this is what it looks like a
little flower I'm just going to keep on
doing these cut a couple out look at
this one look at that color just gonna
add a couple more it's so pretty
last one whoo all right here we have it
the total amount of candy that we made
today
there's our Infinity stones necklace
pieces our little earrings and a lot of
little flowers star-shaped angular
shapes glass pieces I think today and
then pretty good the next step really is
just patience because we have to wait 4
to 6 days for these to dry out
completely now the drying process begins
I will see you guys in 4 to 6 days we
are back here today the Kohaku toe has
hardened I can sort of peel it off it's
like a matte color now smooth surface
gently it feels a little less fragile
see how it doesn't stick together
anymore that's what it looks like now I
was actually turned out pretty well it
like crystallized a little bit more I
don't know if you guys can hear it but
this is the sound that it makes now
these bigger ones it's kind of opaque
these are the trickier ones okay hold on
it looks pretty cool doesn't really look
like a perfect circle anymore here I'm
just glad it's still in one piece
Infinity stones header here we have all
of the Infinity stones nerd moment again
now that I have all of them
now that we have all these pieces I'm
gonna try turning some of these into
actual jewelry these are some little
necklaces and then we also have some
earring things not entirely sure how
this is gonna play out but let's give it
a shot let's just see of these words oh
you see it can you see it let's see if I
can put this through a necklace go ahead
and go in go ahead I got it through I am
NOT somebody who normally wears
accessory I am NOT so not somebody who
normally wears accessories so this is a
how does it look I did not think this is
actually gonna work this is really cool
play with your food candy earrings
totally edible I'm just going to take a
bite because this is edible jury after
all milk fancy and still come
this looks fancy but it's also very
fresh maybe we'll try some more be
ambitious because these works out really
well as you guys can see you can really
customize this and whatever way you why
do different colors different flavors
different shapes and I really just have
fun with it I'm still wearing this so
I'm gonna take these off now and maybe
not eat them I'm really glad I did this
day really glad we were able to pull it
off and see you guys next time
[Music]